what is up boys and girls it is Gerry
I am cruising a boot and I thought I
would stop in and do a quick little
first impressions review for ya it's
been a while wearing sunglasses is very
impersonal but it's bright out uh it's
been a while I haven't seen a movie in a
while I have been very busy it's been a
it's a busy time of year it's been just
does lots of stuff to do lots working
things but I did manage to squeeze in a
trip this week to the cinema I caught
the Beyond fest screening of starry eyes
which is a new independent I guess you'd
call it horror film body horror film and
they played this in a double feature
with a film called possession I didn't
get to stay for possession I have seen
that film before but starry eyes had
heard a lot about it's doing the rounds
on the festival circuit and I was
excited to see it so how was it let's
talk about this to borrow a
colloquialism from the kids I'm just
gonna cut right to the chase here this
movie kind of [ __ ] my [ __ ] up as they
say as they are known to have said yeah
this movie is pretty crazy this movie is
a low-budget it's an independent film I
believe at least some of their funding
came from Kickstarter and stuff like
that and you know it's a little rough
around the edges in places but basically
about this young woman who's trying to
make it as an actress in LA you know
it's early on in her career she's still
very green and very self-conscious of
whatnot and sort of follows her journey
you know trying to live the dream as
they say so she lives with you know a
friend of hers and they have their
little act
Circle that they hang out with there's
some faces you'll recognize in there
like Amanda fuller and Noah Siegen sort
of in her little friend group there Pat
Healy is her boss at the shop she works
at and this movie sort of follows the
evolution of this young woman and she
finally does get something of a break
and all the things that happened to her
after that and I I apologize for being
vague but part of the the the fun of
this movie for me anyway was going in
with very little idea of what was
happening and and you know sort of you
sting my eyes on it as it was happening
it doesn't start out as you know like a
traditional horror movie but slowly but
surely as things you know begin to
spiral out of control and and and sort
of devolve it becomes rather upsetting
and jarring at this very sort of strange
sort of a bleak body horror thing and
it's really cool that this movie starts
out kind of scrappy and plucky much like
the main character doesn't and once it
really finds its footing and gets
confident you know it really packs a lot
of punches this movie isn't like a lot
of things we get nowadays not like a lot
of things you've seen lately but it's
well put together I mean it's it's
low-budget you can tell just from the
look and feel of things that it is a
little bit of low-budget there are a lot
of local locations but it really isn't
confined or restricted by that stuff
which is great this movie is also not
the kind of thing that you have to be
like a Hollywood insider to understand
it's pretty accessible from from any
level and the performances are really
good for the most part Alexander Esso
plays the lead and she's fantastic
I mean first and foremost you know this
movie rests on her a lot she has to
carry a lot of this film and she really
does sell it and that's I mean a lot of
times there are a lot of really good you
know independent scripts out there there
a lot of really cool ideas and whatnot
but sometimes you you really need an
actor or an actress who can sell you
know certain things happening to really
make a movie work and this movie greatly
benefits not only from her performance
but but very much so from her
performance because she is is really
natural very real
and even in the crazy moments she really
commands the role and she really carries
this movie in a lot of ways and the rest
of the cast is good too even the
characters we don't get to know so well
you know everyone turns in a good
performance and there's some phases
you'll recognize Amanda Fuller's in this
no aceton is in this Pat Healey and Mark
Center and you know a few other faces
you might recognize and and most of the
supporting cast does get a chance to
shine even characters who sort of don't
show up a whole lot or given you know
sort of one note to play get a chance to
broaden that over the course of the film
and the performances are all pretty like
really good for the most part also the
effects there are a lot of effects and
I'm not gonna get into necessarily what
type of effect but there are a lot of
effects in this movie practical stuff
and things like that and they look great
especially again for the scale and the
budget of the movie these look better
and more convincing than than some of
the stuff you've seen lately in you know
big budget you know Hollywood movies so
hats off to them for this I mean this
movie really is kind of harrowing and
like it like i said it [ __ ] my [ __ ] up
for a while like it's a it's a jarring
and creepy experience and it gets under
your skin and it's well put together you
know this this arc that this young woman
goes through is twisted and really well
achieved by this film you know it's
still a little bit rough around the
edges and some of the formic elements
but you know once it really hits its
stride you know a quarter or a third of
the way through the movie you know it
really gets going not to say the first
part of the movie doesn't have a stride
but you know it's things pick up a pace
at a certain point and it it gets to a
momentum once she gets to a certain
point
her tail and her career it also serves
this movie well they do give you a good
amount of time to get to know the main
character especially to get to you know
understand her and tend to sort of
identify with her and sympathize with
her before it gets to all the crazy
stuff you know which is invaluable in
any horror movie but especially one like
this where the horror and you know
what's so affecting and creepy and and
you know all the things to get under
your skin are so deeply tied into this
character and her experience you know
they do a really good job at letting you
get to know her first and there are a
lot of elements to the horror in this
movie I mean when the horror kicks in
you do get you know the the sort of
make-up effects stuff and certain gore
effects and things like that later on in
the movie but even early on it does this
cool sort of psychological horror just
with you know the experiences she's
having with people you know in her own
anxieties and and social anxieties
coming out and they do a really cool job
of capturing those events and incidents
in a really creepy and jarring way so
it's not necessarily gory horror all the
time there is that most definitely but
there is also a lot of really cool sort
of semi abstract you know figurative
horror in there too you know where
moments get really stressful for her and
then the the form of the film
accentuates that and that's really cool
about this movie like I said there's
definitely some body horror stuff
there's some like icky disease II makeup
almost there is there's definitely blood
and whatnot but the cool thing about the
horror in this movie is that some of it
is visceral and then some of it just
gets under your skin and his creepy and
gross some of it's just you know weird
to look at you know there's a lot of
different elements that make this movie
freaky but it is certainly a horror
movie once it gets down to brass tacks
so uh yeah differently check this movie
out if you get a chance man especially
if you're in a horror movies if you're
into indie stuff low-budget stuff you
know you want to see something neat and
original
go check out starry eyes I don't know if
and when it's getting distribution on a
wider level I hope it does but if it
goes to VOD or whatever definitely check
it out because there's some twisted
stuff in here some really good effects
some good performances you know some
some good writing and directing and I'm
interested to see what the two guys you
wrote and directed this will come up
with next
so yeah sorry eyes twisted flick really
cool definitely check it out and you
know it's it's a October's coming up I
know we've already sort of talked about
what horror movies you guys are into but
um what's your favorite body horror
movie let's say let's let's talk about
that because that's kind of an
interesting sub genre you don't see a
ton of these days so yeah until next
time guys I am Jerry the movie is starry
eyes Cheers